in this video i want to talk to you
about the tax strategies of the ultra
wealthy and as someone who is ultra
wealthy i find it ironic that the vast
majority of videos that i see on youtube
are made by people who are not ultra
wealthy talking about how the ultra
wealthy do things
when they have no transparency into what
those actions actually are
[Music]
i have gone through i've spent probably
750 000
on different tax advisors different tax
strategies to try and figure out
at least the u.s system to you know
minimize tax drag
and uh the conclusions that i have are
somewhat simple and i want to share this
with you so i can hopefully help you
avoid
a lot of the headaches and pain that i
had to go through in this process
and for context in the last three years
i've spent
18 million dollars or i've paid 18
million dollars in taxes
to the us government and happily done so
uncle sam but
what i want to do is rather than talk
about the little itty bitty hacks i want
to shift your perspective around them
because
um as i've looked into many many many of
these things that are touted as tax
strategies
most of the times they are they are just
tiny little bbs that do not make a
significant difference
and so if i can shift your perspective
around this and get you to think the way
the ultra wealth you think about taxes
then i think that will make a bigger
difference in your life than anything
else will
right off the bat the first thing is
where you live is going to make uh
you know the biggest initial difference
and so first off in the u.s
at a state level where you live is going
to you know you can have a zero tax day
versus you know california is a 15 or 16
tax date plus all the other taxes they
tack on everything else you do
and so you know the first and obvious
thing to do is you can live into live in
a lower tax state
now the second level of this is what
country you live in and so
if you are a u.s resident you you suffer
from uh
global taxation meaning it doesn't
matter where you live they're going to
tax you and so there's only two ways
to get around federal tax the first is
to live in puerto rico
six months of the year and export
services from puerto rico
if that is you you can do that it's a
four percent federal tax rate so you can
have zero percent state four percent
federal
and live there it's 100 legit it is
legal to do that the other way to do it
is to expatriate meaning you stop
becoming a us resident you renounce your
citizenship
um as a u.s citizen and then you come
back basically as an alien the way that
you
do that is you can become a citizen by
investment you spend a million dollars
uh in investment uh into the us and then
you get basically a golden visa which
means you pay for it
and again though you have to be here
less than you know six months of the
year otherwise you then become a u.s tax
resident again even if you're
uh not a us uh citizen so the the big
conclusion here is
in the beginning you know get out of the
states that are you know the high tax
states move to a state that is
lower tax but what i want to do is shift
your perspective around this overall
big picture because if you look at how
your wealth will compound and again this
is why i said this is tax strategies of
the ultra wealthy
the vast majority of your net worth is
going to come from growth
not the contributions okay and so if you
plug your money into or what your what
your
retirement calculator you can google
when they're all over the place you'll
be able to see
that the vast majority of your net worth
over time is going to come from the
growth of the assets that are in it
not from the contributions and it comes
mostly from starting early
and so that is why i'm such a big
proponent of living on absolutely
nothing for as long as humanly possible
so that you can
so you can start using the compounding
interest of time to your advantage
and for perspective for everyone who's
listening to this don't think
right now i can only put 500 a month
aside it's not going to make a big
difference
the thing is is that 500 a month when
you are 20 will make a bigger difference
than 5 000 a month when you are 45. so
think about that for perspective
all right the dollars now count 10 times
more than the dollars in 10 years and so
forth okay
so that's number one the second thing
that the ultra wealthy do in terms of
uh tax considerations is that they think
differently about how they buy
so for example if i buy something that's
worth a hundred dollars for thirty
dollars i
instantly tripled my money except i
didn't pay tax on that tripling right
because the value of what i purchased is
worth three times more
than what i paid for it but the beauty
of this is that
i get that gain without having to pay
taxes on it and then it continues to
grow and compound again without taxation
and so the vast majority of much wealthy
people understand this and they and they
structure their life and their
investments in that way
which leads me to the third thing which
is how slash if you sell
so the only reason that the the tax rate
is going to matter to you is if you
pay capital gains and that means that
you've chosen to sell
but there are a lot of strategies around
buying and holding you look at warren
buffett
he's held he's held seized candy for how
you know 30 something years or 40
something years
same thing with coca-cola right same
thing with geico he continues to buy
things and hold them because he realizes
that the tax treatment
is going to be so efficient if you buy
correctly and so the goal is to think
from the perspective of not i'm going to
buy it and try and flip this i'm going
to hold this for five years or this
company looks good for this month
is do i think that this thing is going
to last for a very long time
and if so i will get disproportionate
returns by buying safe
and buying something that's going to be
here in 30 years then trying to buy
something sexy now
and so if you can understand that then
you buy things to hold them for the long
term
because the biggest shift in perspective
the ultra wealthy have versus the not
wealthy
is that they think in longer time
horizons they think about generational
wealth they don't think about what i'm
going to pay for
this month how can buy a car or whatever
the fancy stuff that leads naturally to
the fancy stuff which is like well if
i'm buying all these things how am i
going to live my life later
good question well the cool thing about
how the u.s tax code works is that
loans are never treated as income but
they are
spendable money that you can consume and
use and so for example if i continue to
plow all of my money into
assets that earn while i sleep which is
the definition of wealth that i gave you
one of my other videos
if they continue to grow and they are
growing tax-free then the growth that is
tax-free
i can i can realize by taking loans
against those things and i can use those
loans to live my life
and as long as the loans that i'm taking
are less than the growth of my assets
then i can use all of that growth
continue to let it compound tax free for
the rest of my life
and live off the loans and when i dab
they can they can rectify my account
and so these are the strategies of the
people who are ultra wealthy
the things when they talk about
conservation easements which is uh
basically you donate land and you get
the full value of the land even though
you didn't pay the full value
it's it's a bb right you're not going to
be able to put your entire income
against that
uh you know captive insurance i've got a
friend of mine who was like dude do this
thing with me and say and for me it
ended up
it was going to save like 250 thousand a
year which honestly doesn't make a big
dent for me
and it wasn't really worth the hassle so
i was like i don't know this was a
little fishy guess what happened the irs
ended up flipping the their rule
ruling on it saw people taking advantage
of it and then they back
back charge people with interest and
fees right and so the thing is is that
the us tax code is not fair because the
government can change the rules whenever
they want they can say you know what we
changed this rule this year and we're
going to back text people three years
they can do that because they have
complete control there's nothing we can
do about it
right i like to think about it just like
i think about content on any kind of
platform is that i just have to align
within the rules that
that exist and long term if i don't sell
anything
i'm not going to get taxed on it and so
the idea long term is
live for less than i you know for as low
as i possibly can if you like island
living then by all means go and live on
an island if you if you so choose
for me i've chosen not to do the puerto
rico thing because the difference in
net worth for me makes no difference in
my life because the difference between
having a hundred million dollars and 180
million dollars
to me makes no difference and so i
got into this game because i wanted to
have used money to have freedom to do x
y z
right to live where i wanted to live to
do what i wanted to do with whom i
wanted to do it right
and so if that is the goal of what the
money is going to afford me
i can't put the money above the freedom
and so if i have to remain prisoner of
an island for six months of the year in
order
to get my a better income tax rate right
then it seems like it's putting
the cart before the horse for me it's
i'm i'm relinquishing the original
objective i had
and making the path or the vehicle the
objective rather than realizing that
money in it of itself has no value
it only has value in so far as it allows
me to do things that i want to do
and so if i'm forgetting that which many
of us do because the game is so enticing
then i think that that is what makes
that more uh reasonable a lot of people
end up rationalizing no you know i love
island living but
i'll tell you what the reason that they
give you that four percent is because
it's not that sick
so for me i think the easy thing me
living in texas versus california
the the living lifestyle is the same for
me uh but i but i pay less
fewer taxes worth it makes sense to me
living in puerto rico
i'm relinquishing a lot of freedoms
there and i have to be there six plus
months of the year
and for me that's very difficult with
outages and and
basically no stores that are interesting
and not a lot to do i'm not going to
give up the half of my life literally
um so that i can get half more money on
my net worth because as much as people
are like well that 40
is going to compound well so is the
other 60. and so again
i think it makes sense if you are if you
were smaller and you were starting out
and you're trying to develop your net
worth
but i can tell you right now the vast
majority of your worth is going to come
from the growth and none of that has to
be taxed
and so if you play the game the right
way which is the way the ultra wealthy
play they're not trying to think about
all these little hacks and codes that
you see on the internet here
it's really about making sure that you
understand the big rocks correctly which
is
buy low immediately get value on your
money for buying for less than what
something's worth
when you sell it or don't sell it at all
you can continue to take loans against
the increased
value of the assets and you can live off
this rest of your life if you so choose
and so these are the tax strategies of
the ultra wealthy from someone who
actually is ultra wealthy i hope you
found value in this video
click subscribe and i'll see you in the
next bit bye